here's a question I have for you Luke uh
you you made the Bold Claim about the
Satanist influence in the music industry
and we hear a lot of this stuff from
back in the day about like playing
records backwards and it's like a secret
message but what's going on what what
what information I I don't ever claim to
know what's going on I just have a lot
of questions that I think should be
answered questions I think I think
specifically people in the music
industry you know are exposed to a lot
of The Insider dealings that that we
don't we we aren't preview to and that's
why I was kind of looking to ask you
guys what you you guys seen because I I
think it's pretty clear there is some
kind of satanic demonic influence
whether it's just done as parody or
whether there's some deeper meaning to
it you see the lyrics you see the
symbology and it's and it's overt and
you see a lot of the same things a lot
of the same lyrics saying I sold my soul
to the devil I don't I don't claim to
know exactly what's going on here but
being in the music industry how do you
guys well real quick I'm gonna get a
button for my stream deck that plays a
sound bite from Boondock Saints when um
Willem Dafoe says symbolism
when the guy says symbology that's a
good movie that's a good movie so yeah
what's going on man so we we see it too
I mean look at the the biggest artists
in the world are getting on the MTV
Movie Awards and then you look at the
subliminal messages behind you look at
even Disney uh you know they did
something in the Cruella Deville Movie
that that
you know had like Satan on the front on
entrance of her house like that you know
what I mean or the car like like there
there's all these little uh devil
references and then and music listen to
the lyrics listen to some of the most
popular artists in the world you got
Billy eilish who the title her song is
called I'm the bad guy right what little
my daughter is listening to that she's
seven eight years old I'm the bad guy
dad you know like you you've got the
most popular rappers talking about
overdosing on drugs you've got these are
the messages
that the kids listen are falling into
right that that's first of all those are
the biggest artists in the world that
promote they're promoting and then you
look at the the fashion side of things
what was his name little Nas X is on
there with blood in his shoes and the
club they're they're what are they
called the their their hoes they have
the the split in the top clothing
dressed in all red dress then they also
say there's Satanic rituals with the
with the white and black floors in the
videos like if you look at some of the
biggest artists in the world like it
might be Jay-Z might be one of them you
know you almost gets scared to say some
of these people's names when they shoot
the videos they say that that they they
shoot some of these videos on the black
and white floors and all this stuff like
these places are where like like rituals
happen whether there have been like
sacrifices like you you hear these
rumors in the music industry and and I
don't think a lot of it's rumors I think
that there is but but check us out
something changed and maybe it was an
anomaly but I remember when I was little
the first CD I ever got Americana
offspring and so they have a hit song
it's huge song it's called The Kids
Aren't all right the song is literally
just lamenting the demise of like the
family and Urban Decay it's literally
him singing a song about how these kids
nothing's free you know uh chances
Throne longing forward it used to be
like wanting to go back to another time
people doing drugs getting pregnant
dropping out that's what the song's
about and it's negative depictions of
that they had another song on that album
that that was a huge hit why don't you
get a job and then I'm like you know I'm
thinking about this a few years ago and
I was like man those guys were actually
pretty conservative by today's standards
then they put out a song a few years
later called hit that which is a song
lamenting the fact that lamenting hookup
culture and that people aren't getting
married anymore and I'm liar these guys
are like strangely traditionalist but of
course now today they're like you're
fired from the band because dude could
not get a vaccine but it's just weird to
see that back in the 90s the you know
aside from Pretty Fly for a Wagoner
bunch of songs on an album that are just
literally you know like have a family
and get a job you know and don't let
your kids do drugs I I gotta say I think
Satan gets a bad rep uh Lucifer in
general I think well person I don't like
it and I don't like evil and I don't
like blood magic I get pretty turned off
by those things but I think the
propaganda of the Bible is like there
were some cultists they were taking
psychedelics Michael the Archangel and
Lucifer and all these dudes taking and
they were channeling God communicating
but Michael was the leader and
eventually maybe they were hoarding
knowledge that they were like it's too
dangerous for them they can't have the
light they can't have fire you can't
teach them how to make fire or maybe his
electricity can't give them flashlights
and Lucifer is like no you can't hoard
Knowledge from people so we went and
he's the lightbringer he brought the
Common People the ability to make life
sane and Lucifer are different so
Lucifer I'm talking about and
luciferianism or whatever and then so
he's like and they cast them out and
then they demon they win they go to war
there's a war over it and then Michael
wins his cult wins and then they write a
Bible about a book about it and make him
the debt the most evil thing
first cancel culture ever or the first
one is luciferous the first canceled I
don't know man it sounds like propaganda
Ian yeah sure does look at Britney
Spears look at no you sound like profit
oh well it's all propaganda and you know
Brittany has come out and and you know
the media will cover every single time
her hair is a mess in public or every
time that she makes a video where she
looks like she had a glass of wine but
she came out and did an entire interview
about how she was at Satanic rituals in
the music industry that she was at
events where they did this they had
orgies with masks on she was at she that
came out and had said that she's seen
this up with her eyes no media coverage
no one talked about it nothing but you
will see media coverage on when she
looked crazy on Tick-Tock doing a dance
so it it's it's an interesting is it
bloodline
a lot of those Disney stars uh that that
were brought up in the industry and
became famous later on in their life a
lot of them are dealing with some
significant problems especially with
their upbringing especially with the
industry that brought them up and a lot
of them do talk about a lot of abuse
that happens to them which I think is
important important to note and
important to talk about I don't know if
you guys have any insights to that
particularly well now just the same as
you right you hear you hear all the
people the child stars of of our eight
of the 80s and 90s you know we're all
paranoid and they tell their stories
about what happened to them they were
you know like I think everyone knows the
elephant in the room is that there are
certain certain groups of powerful
people in this world that like children
right I mean I can't attest for any of
the theories
that's a fact at this point I mean right
yeah I mean I I have personal friends
that literally do them sold their soul
to the devil to become the best guitar
player in the world and their lives are
ruined so but they think they did is
that what it is they would they would
prick their finger put it put their
blood on a contract write a contract out
sign it and they said I sold my soul to
the devil to become the greatest guitar
player in the world and now they're
druggies somewhere and you know yeah in
the street whether you believe Satan or
not that person's life is ruined for
what they believed in I don't like blood
magic because blood's fascinating and
people work with it like my girlfriend
works with blood she like does like
diabetes will like put people up to
machines and stuff I think Cara if I'm
getting that wrong sorry about that um
but she works with it and it's like it's
a fascinating substance but like Maria
Abramovich does like blood sick cooking
where they like paint blood spear
cooking and it's like to get fascinated
with blood to love blood is one thing we
all got it but to get obsessive with it
is [ __ ] crazy
yeah we're like you can't do it without
the because it's got It's magnetic
there's iron in it so it's Gotta that's
why we have these magnetic you know
um dynamos so these these magnetic
fields the big part is because the iron
and the blood man like an X-Men when
Magneto was like too much iron in the
blood and then rips it out of his body
and then he makes little things and he's
like flying around yeah they get magic
is magnetic that mag you know prefix uh
well there's a lot of people that even
go as far as to compare music to mind
control because of the repetitive nature
of it because of the symbology because
of the lyrics because people listening
and also seeing it as a form of
entertainment which of course makes them
put their guards down and they're able
to of course subconsciously pick up a
lot of the larger messaging so there's a
lot of conversations about that
specifically I don't know if you guys
are aware of it but another thing I
wanted to also if you want to enter if
you want to go go right ahead but but
another thing I also wanted to talk
about is a lot of artists and a lot of
creative people usually say that their
music or their art they're usually just
a vessel for it and somehow when they're
creating music or art they have
something else speak kind of through
them you see this kind of described a
lot by a lot of very creative people I
don't know if you guys have any kind of
examples of 100 yeah I feel like
uh when when I talk about the the most
successful songs I've ever had and that
I've written in my life I I have to
attach the word blessed to it because
these these ideas came to me through
like like I'm a vessel right like like
whether it's full Melodies choruses
lyrics everything just like it just
happens and then it changes my life and
then and then it changes the the lives
of the listeners the fans I've had the
most fulfilling stories I've ever gotten
uh uh you know money money aside like
the things that that have really
fulfilled me the most in music is when
someone comes up and says uh your song
Somebody wishes they were you changed my
life it made me look at life differently
you know I really appreciate and have
more gratitude now where I was thinking
of doing something bad to myself and
then you know I heard some crazy stories
along the way I was thinking about doing
something bad to myself this song came
on I never heard of you before it spoke
to me and then I went into a rehab and
and changed my life like these are the
stories that are Priceless to me these
are the stories when we were out on the
road and we were getting robbed for
everything we had you know working nine
months out of the Year going home and
nothing you know because we were selling
all these terrible contracts
um these were the stories that I'd lay
in bed and I'd say you know what man you
might not have any money you might be
working hard you might be you know
sacrificing all your relationships with
your lifelong friends your wife your
family but you're making an impact on
people's lives and and that drove me for
for years and yes it was the vessel that
that helps write these songs I can
definitely say that there is a spiritual
connection between being the vessel to
writing songs and connecting to people
and the definite energetic one that
can't be really described in words and a
lot of people have a hard time even
quantifying in in sentences because it's
it's how do you describe this kind of
this feeling this emotion that overtakes
a lot of people even when they listen to
a particular song which of course is
usually connected with their emotions so
there's there's still so many other
things I want to ask you there's also of
course the the 432 Hertz conspiracy I
don't know if you guys heard to that one
uh but the key event there's a lot of
different stuff out there but uh you
know we're just touching we're just
touching the surface when you drum does
it take over you
yeah at a certain point I mean when a
performance starts your your focused and
then I mean you could just contribute
that to Adrenaline as well you know like
he turns into a different person when he
drones I see it every night I see it
every night there's another there's a
there's like a suit you watch someone go
like super saiyan you know and like when
Dragon Ball Z characters would like hit
the hit the gas and their hairs would go
like blonde and they'd have a whole
energy Aura that's what it's like
watching him drum for for 15 years for
me man I see him start going and and and
people are like you guys got so much
energy on stage it's because he's he's
feeding me who already has all this
energy I'm feeding the crowd it's like
our our shows our live shows are like a
ball of energy circulating throughout a
room and and you know let's talk about
that that 400 Hertz conspiracy what is
that about Luke well there's different
theories out there I haven't looked into
it that much but there's a theory that
music used to be in a healing frequency
and then it was turned into a frequency
that's more disruptive you might know
more about this than I do because I just
looked at the surface level it's either
it's one of those uh World Elite
Rothschilds or something that changed
the standard tuning from 432 Hertz to
440 Hertz
um 432 Hertz
brings out the harmonic Resonance of the
notes and you get a lot more harmonics
and saturation and and the musical notes
and all original music like Beethoven
all those Original Classic composers
played in fourth to 432 Hertz their
pianos were tuned for 32 Hertz
um
even the Beatles did some 432 Hertz
music as well oh my God I pulled it up
here we got it from Global News the
great 440 Hertz conspiracy and why all
of our music is wrong
they say gather around kids those of you
with tin foil hats may wish to ensure
that they're fitted snugly what I'm
about to tell you will shake your faith
and all the music you've heard of your
life if you look down the right paths it
becomes clear that governments and
various security apparatuses have used
music to control us oh no
all the music of the West it's based on
the Standard 12 tone scale is used for
the management of crowds so as well as
thought control
they say if musical performances were to
sound the same the world over some
standardization was required as early as
1885 the music Commission of the Italian
government declared that all instruments
and orchestras should use a tuning fork
that vibrated at 440 Hertz which was
different from the original standard of
435 and the competing 432 used in France
in 1917 the American Federation
musicians endorsed the Italians followed
by a further push for 440 Hertz in the
40s in 1953 a worldwide agreement was
signed signatories declare that the
middle a on the piano be forever more
tuned to exactly 440 Hertz this
frequency became the standard ISO 16
reference for tuning all musical
instruments
so what is it they say no one can say
for sure why so what's the conspiracy
what are you writing about well that's
like it's driving people crazy adherence
this Theory claimed the more natural
frequency or middle a is 438 others
believe the correct middle is 432
because there's a pure tone of math
fundamental to Nature and is
mathematically consistent with the
patterns of the universe vibrating with
fee Phi the golden ratio they point to
how this pitch can be connected to
everything from Nautilus shells to the
works of the Ancients including the
constructs of the Great Pyramid that
proves it so it's time to change all of
our tunings the reason I brought this up
is because I saw a scientific experiment
I think like 20 years ago when I was a
child and it had a box of sand and it
put it over a speaker and it played
different uh hurts and it different and
it played a different music and you
could see the shape of the hurt of the
music that was translated from the
grains of sand that were moved through
the speaker and some of the sand was
very disruptive and all over the place
and really nasty and some of it looked
like snowflakes uh pure perfect uh
synchronistic images and you know this
is where we get into a lot of the bigger
kind of deeper hippie dippy stuff when
it comes to what the bleep do you know
and other kind of documentaries like
what are the great mystery that of
course talk about this in great detail
when it comes to
um you know perfectly aligned alleged
healing for frequencies and that's what
we hear sometimes again I'm not an
expert in this I just remember this
sitting here from 20 years ago it's
called chimatics is where you use sound
to alter matter what we're going to say
so like when you tune from 440 to 432
that's 32 cents lower so
it it gives it more of a slower feeling
as well so I create meditation
relaxation music with elevated and
everything's tuned to 432 Hertz and that
works better for that style of music
when you want to chill and you want to
relax
440 could could be you know leveling it
up to give a more energy you know it
might not be no crazy conspiracy theory
stuff it could just be like hey we want
more energy like I know that um Kiss
From a Rose
that's still right he he wanted his song
without changing the tempo to have more
energy so he brought up his two and he's
like 442 so he brought it up because he
wanted to give it more energy with just
tuning it up just a slight yeah I mean
to the to the to like the untrained ear
you can't really tell not even from 4 40
to 4 30 you can't really tell it's more
of a feeling yeah soul and feeling is is
so important that's why I think that it
could be a little I don't know enough
about it but I know I write from like
the just just the soul and I don't
overthink that stuff too much when I'm
going into a key or a range so and I
know that that that's worked so maybe
there's a lot of ways to eat a Reese's
right you know yeah like I mean think
about colonization of of the Native
American population by the Europeans
where the Native Americans chilling in
432 and but Native Americans were 432
and and so it didn't the Native
Americans were 432. if you buy if you go
get like a natural made Native American
flute and naturally comes in fourth or
two Hertz and they weren't out there
engine nearing weapons and I mean they
were they had their own types but not
like the Europeans not like gunpowder
and explosives and physics to shoot
cannons and like just that aggro go go
go conquer take I wonder if that's it
there was Native American tribes that
were like that Ian that did conquer
other tribes that did were very
combative that that did enslave other
populations that did conduct Human
Sacrifice they were way more brutal than
Europeans brutal yeah but not
technologically advanced they would rip
that starts out on the top pyramids
calling in their entities because they
wanted better farming but it's like the
aggravation that prompts engineering
like I got to figure it out something's
wrong I got to figure it out where I was
like yo something's wrong no something's
fine everything's cool just chill like
that's the Native American style whereas
the European would be like something's
wrong let's fix it
I'm generalizing too of course but
that's just not absolutely not true yeah
you're talking you're talking about a
wind a population that that solely lived
in in you know areas with winter save
the Mediterranean and then you have
North America with a wide range of
different temperatures especially in
like the desert or the South where it's
typically hot Native Americans lived in
Florida where it's tropical so these
things play a huge role in whether or
not someone needs to strive towards
something you live in Florida you don't
got to worry all that much because the
growing season is every day of every
year but for Europe the growing season
is they've got to deal with winter that
means if you don't work you don't
survive that's why they get
technological advancements there's no
there's no rage around it was heavily
populated too they're true because after
that flood 13 000 years ago that that
flood wiped out Native American wiped
out America like all the population of
the of North America got smear at least
the United States got smeared into tar
by that glacial flow I'm pretty sure
that's not true I'm pretty sure that
there was a massive pandemic that wiped
out most of the Native Americans I'm
talking about 13 12 800 years ago at the
end of the last uh younger dryas uh
Randall Carlson's the guy to go to for
the geological surveys on this stuff but
there's a layer of black sediment tar
where all the megaphone of the giraffes
and stuff were just smeared into dirt no
no I'm sorry I'm sorry you're wrong
because everyone knows everybody knows
that there was already a great
civilization that was here and this mud
flood can't dance swept through and then
buried those buildings and we we were
only discovering them that's why
Chicago's underground that proves it so
my final question is should we return
the music to 432 yes
I hereby decree From This Moment forward
do you guys stop your music in that
frequency or do you guys have a I don't
know because when you get a snark a
tuner you put on your guitar it tells
you that a is what it is it's just
measuring 440. nowadays it's very
difficult to to do your music in 440
because all the virtual instruments are
naturally tuned to 440 so if you're
doing 432 I mean yeah 432 yeah so if
you're gonna go in and put virtual
instruments on on your recordings you
literally have to tune everything down
to 432 and it they make it really
difficult
talking about that proves to conspiracy
that's right maybe when you talk about
the brutality of History like he's
talking about like people were over
overrunning civilizations and doing that
doesn't make doesn't it make you feel
like our our generation is being
conditioned to not be prepared for
anything like that like like if you're
if right now I feel like if if I said to
someone I'd be ready to fight for my
household or I'd be ready to defend
Trevor or you know do whatever I would
be looked at in a negative light right
it would be like oh
he's he's a toxic male or whatever it
may be right it feels that way nowadays
uh when I'm when you get ready for
nothing right when you're like
defensively prepared for Stuff uh it
almost feels like we're being softened
up
pretty pretty bad Our Generation I don't
know and when you talk about history
back in the day like people were
brutalizing colonies and doing all this
stuff it's in history and and now you've
got it like it's it's so frowned upon to
be ready for anything like that so
you're like a loser but just really
quick many people don't understand how
blessed and how absolutely lucky we are
especially here in the United States
especially living here you you travel
the world other people are not living
like this we are fully over abundant and
we are living an extremely to the
contrary good times good times that
leads to weakness I think weak men that
lead to bad times and I think we're on
that precipice where we're going into
the bad times that's why we all have a
responsibility to maintain the
awesomeness of the United States so we
can help the rest of the world when
Shea's rebellion was snapping off in
1778 all these farmers were like no I
don't have the money to pay off your
fret debts to France we can't they try
to seize their property the farmers like
hell no they went to the courthouses
they surrounded them
they shut it all down people were
getting hurt uh they ended up but
whatever they they someone set Thomas
Jefferson a letter and they're like yo
it's popping off there's a rev it looks
like there's gonna be a revolution
Thomas Jefferson was like good good we
need revolutions it keeps the government
honest
yeah that was his response you used like
you said it's great here and and you
could use the rest of the world as an
example but it also puts a little fear
in you right we don't I don't want that
here I don't when I think about the
civilians of a place like China I feel
so bad for them I feel like when is a
superhero going to go and and liberate
them right like I just don't want I
think that that we're not getting closer
to those people being you know freed
from this tyranny I think we're getting
closer to being
run by tyranny in a sense except our
generation right now us uh the people
listening the next batch of people that
are that are that are ready to just
speak about it
openly talk about what's happening and
and be as prepared as you can be right
we don't want to to go to war do
anything crazy right obviously that's
that's what it seems the powers that be
want but we can't just not be ready and
we can't just not be you know
understanding that in the rest of the
world it's this type of way and we're
the only place that isn't that type of
way like my fear is losing
how great it is and what we have losing
our Liberty losing our freedom who who
is if we're all being conditioned and
not be ready to fight for that or ready
to to stand up for these things and
we're always just standing down who can
be brave yeah we have a gift and we're
taking it for granted the First
Amendment the Second Amendment is rare
many civilizations many countries many
empires never had those kind of
Liberties that they allowed citizens to
have a part of their organizations now
in the first time one of the first times
we're experimenting with freedom and now
there's a Sinister group that wants to
take it away from us which is absolutely
insane thanks for checking out this
segment from the timcast IRL podcast but
if you want to check out the full show
live tune in Monday through Friday at 8
pm and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there